[Music]
hello and a very warm welcome indeed to
quadriga coming to you from the heart of
Berlin and the focus is on Israel which
is this week celebrating the 70th
anniversary of the birth of the Jewish
state in 1948 ceremonies have been
taking place in Jerusalem and elsewhere
across the country to mark the
achievements of the past seven decades
that have made today's Israel a
democracy a military superpower and a
technological heavyweight but for the
Palestinians the emergence of Israel was
a catastrophe ever since they've been
battling for what they believe is their
land their rights and their future at
least 30 Palestinians have been killed
and many more wounded in the latest
clashes on the border with Gaza so our
question here on quadriga this week is
Israel at 70 a troubled anniversary and
to discuss that question I'm joined here
in the studio by offer vault man who's a
musician and journalist he's also head
of the German section of the new Israel
fund which is committed to supporting
civil society in Israel and Palestinian
rights
Olfa says 70 years of Independence 50
years of occupation Israel stands at the
most crucial crossroads in its history
also with this is Akram Baker a Middle
East analyst and political consultant
Akram argues that with its ever
increasing right-wing nature Israel at
70 is accelerating the end of the
Zionist experiment and a warm welcome to
to Shani Rose honest Deutsche Welle
own producer and commentator based here
in Berlin Shani says only 70 years old
Israel is still a young democracy in
formation thank you all for being here
I'd like to begin with you offer vote
man 70 years of Israel have you been
celebrating well that's a difficult
question when I was talking to my
parents who live in Jerusalem I could
still feel the excitement in their
voices they remember actually when
Israel was founded they were there in
1948 so for them it still it still a
miracle the Israeli state from the other
hand looking at the news we are from
Israel these days and the demonstrations
in Gaza
conflict with Iran I hope that Israel
will be able to confront its it's state
in a way that will that will make sure
that we will celebrate in ten twenty or
seventy years ahead again you mentioned
Jerusalem you were born in Jerusalem and
I saw that you were quoted as saying
that you believe that Jerusalem is a
state of mind I'd like to take that just
a little bit further and assume that
Israel is a state of mind
describe that state of mind for us at
this point in time well it was this
quote was made regarding the decision of
the American President to move the
American Embassy to Jerusalem and it was
very controversial in Israel and outside
of Israel and my take was that actually
it was a good decision because Jerusalem
as the capital city of Israel represents
Israel this is a place where you have
citizens and then you have hundreds of
thousands of people who are not citizens
and you have a separation between
different groups between Arabs and
Israelis Raley's so in that sense
Jerusalem Israel is a state of mind
reminding us the I would say the
challenges with which Israel is
confronted and actually way too here in
Germany mmm sherizaan is also an Israeli
citizen based here in Germany working
for Deutsche Welle
Israel at 70 what does it mean to you
well you know there's lots of trouble
there's a lot of challenges but but I
want to break the gloom and doom fest I
feel we're about to launch here because
it's been seven years for what was an
incredible miraculous act of statehood I
mean this is and and if you put this in
the context of nation-building 70 years
is not a long time and these challenges
that Israel is facing and some of them
are pressing and needs to be solved
sooner rather than later
they cannot you know they cannot
overshadow everything we need to still
keep in mind you know offer was talking
about his parents remembering how it was
when there was no state there if you put
this in context we bring ourselves back
to 1948 to the to the to the survivors
of the Holocaust one of the biggest
tragedies most atrocious you know parts
of human history
together and managing to build this
state having made many mistakes as well
but with great determines and dream and
aspirations and it's it's something that
you know when you think about it it's
hard not to because when I talk about
these achievements what are you most
proud of well it the culture part of it
you know the Hebrew and the culture that
surrounds it and these are the thinkers
and the Philosopher's and the and the
writers and the poets and also that
bring us hope you know this is the
things that keep us going 70 years on
when we look at it where it happens in
the political sphere on one hand and
maybe you're some of us are really
critical some for that's this one thing
but then it's real as a society there's
a strong society too has a strong civil
society it has very strong independent
press these independent voices coming
from that culture of liberal thinking of
of critical thinking of their own
government as well this is still part of
Israel as well and we need to keep it in
mind that that's where the hopely is you
know this is where we're looking at the
next 70 years this is where we need to
hold on to and hold for better Charlie
Rose artists has used the word hope of
three four five six times there in that
statement she's talked about a great
feat of state building what's your take
on this well I just I just wanna hark
back to he says it's a state of mind
it's been a nightmare if that's a state
of mind for us for Palestinians for the
past 70 years and just to touch on
you're the grandfather of modern Hebrew
as our Leibowitz was one of the largest
proponents of Palestinian statehood and
Palestinian rights to exist is Israel is
a it's a Zionist experiment and if we
want to talk about the Holocaust and the
horrors of that the promise that most of
some of the most violated people in
Israel have been the survivors of the
Holocaust many of them of those
survivors are very Pro Palestinian and
have been against what the State of
Israel has done unfortunately Israel has
continued to use and continues to use
the Holocaust as an excuse for its
policies whereas the Holocaust was a
crime against Jews was a crime against
also gays and and Roma and Sinti and
many other people but it was a crime by
Europeans against their own people it
had nothing to do with Palestine and the
injustice that was done to Palestinians
the fact is that your miracle was
created on our catastrophe it was
created through an injustice and right
now for me to say I want the destruction
of Israel so I can build a state of
Palestine would be nothing but another
injustice which I don't want to happen
but it's your policies it's the policies
of the Israeli government and this
transformation of Israeli society into a
right wing vicious society which is
hastening its own goodness
before you come back on that Sunday
let's see we've got some images for the
viewers and then I'll come straight back
to you absolutely because the birth of
the State of Israel 70 years ago as
we've just seen came shortly after the
end of the Second World War and the
Holocaust the mass murder of European
Jews this shocking chapter of European
history still casts a shadow over
Israeli society never again will we
allow ourselves to be made victims say
the Israelis and the declaration of the
State of Israel by David ben-gurion in
1948 gave Jews around the world their
own homeland but Israel immediately
found itself at war with five Arab
nations during the conflict hundreds of
thousands of Palestinians fled from
their homelands in what they called the
neck bar or catastrophe
Shawny two groups of people fighting for
the same homeland yes but right but I
think and I think I think this is
unfortunately that the challenge that
Israelis have failed to take upon them
right I mean in a good way to
independent fix but I don't think that
acknowledging the Palestinian suffering
is contradicting the belief that Jews
have placed in the land of Palestine and
I think both Palestinians and Jews well
please the moderate moderate ones know
and understand these two people will
have to find way to coexist okay
of success is a tragedy and and there's
no doubt if you're looking at who's
paying that price of that tragedy we're
in that you guys there's no there's no
doubt and who's who's carrying the
burden on his shoulders but if we look
at the few I mean into the future then
just like you said
no one will benefit from the demise of
the State of Israel as a Jewish state
it's about finding a way to make this
work for both people somehow can I just
interject I'm sorry just one thing
I completely object to a Jewish state
just as I object to a Muslim State or
Krishna State or a Buddha state it
cannot there's no such thing as a
democracy in a Jewish state you have
been looking very thoughtful yeah well
it is a Middle Eastern discussion and
belief in Germany so I find both halves
of my personality struggling with each
other well first of all I think Israel
was founded not only because of the
Holocaust that would have been the State
of Israel or a kind of a holistic Jewish
entity in Palestine with or without the
Holocaust this is important I think the
lesson is much more to think we have to
remember from the Holocaust especially
now that we're moving from remembering
the Holocaust as having the Holocaust as
a part of the human history because the
last victims and the last perpetrator on
dying is the universalistic lessons it
gives us and I must say you know when
you speak it out Israel is only 70 years
old and we have to let to give you time
we have a basic construction flaw in the
in the in the heart of this beautiful
house called the stage of Israel and
this is the failed partnership with
Palestinians the vid cost man the great
writer said a few days ago in the
israel-palestinian commemoration day he
said Israel will not be a home bite bait
in Arabic without us to be able without
the Palestinians having at home and
without us being to - to cooperate and
when you say Israel is a great country
it does and Israel has critical social a
civil society well I can tell you
speaking is there ahead of a new Israel
fund here in Germany the Israeli civil
society the critical voices within
Israel are standing under massive
attacks from one side of Israeli
politics because you know the critic
that we sound we say that if this
construction flaw that wherever the
foundation of our over a joint home will
not be corrected if
will not find a way to cooperate with
the Palestinians and I I disagree I
don't think that Jewish straight you can
compare it to a Christian state but if
we won't start to talk to each other
then it's not that in 70 years only 100
years the State of Israel be older and
wiser and we learn from its mistakes I
believe that if we if we keep on like
this there will be no State of Israel as
we know it today please ladies first no
I just I I think there's no doubt I was
starting with saying there are
challenges there's there's many problems
and I I don't think we can we can the
minute I mean the little or diminish any
of them and the urgency for for for
solution but then at the same time I
just I just refuse to fall into this
endless hopeless bleak look into the
future and thinking this it's not going
nowhere there's a difference between the
political regime that we see now and
even it feels like it's been there
forever and it's gonna stay forever but
life and politics is not like that and
there could be a situation in two three
four or five years things might look
better they might not but we need to
find people the critical voices the
people within the civil society the
journalists need to fight to make sure
that the changes are made in the right
direction but I don't think I mean I
think if you look at the core there's a
lot to work with those good people those
good thoughts on both sides and I think
at this particular day one day of the
year I want to try and and stick to hope
you really wanted to use their good
people on both sides may I just say that
I agree with you and that and with over
that there has to be the solution that
the problem is that the Zionist
narrative does not allow for the
Palestinians right to exist as a nation
I believe that there will be an end to
Israel as a Jewish state which I hope
there will be an end to Israel as a
Jewish state and there will be a real
democratic state call it Israel call it
Palestine call it whatever you want
where one person has equal rights under
the law that this is
land for all of the people who live
there Jews Christians atheists Muslims
Buddhists whoever you like that that the
state is for its citizens and for the
people who live there
not for one religion over another that's
the only way that Israel seems like the
hopeless optimist is you not me at this
time of celebration jubilation in Israel
the 70th anniversary a lot of people are
talking about outsiders are talking
about the achievements that Israel has
has made you know in your your
dismissing the end of the very notion
already but people talk about the
flourishing economy people talk about
democracy in Israel do you dismiss all
of this out of hand and deal would you
say that
similar achievements haven't necessarily
been made on the Palestinian side
because the Israelis have been there are
not two sides of Peter Peter there are
not two sides there's not Israel and
there's Palestine Israel is the master
Israel controls everything they occupy
Palestine Palestine if anything is a
state of mind it is not anywhere on a
map to be found it has no controls
Israel controls everything so let's get
that right
so taught the fact that people have been
celebrating of course these are the
enablers these are the same enablers who
have allowed the Israeli economy to
flourish with my tax dollars as an
American and Israel lives in a bubble
take away the American tax dollars take
away all the subsidies your Israeli
economy will not be so would not be
flourishing so much and then another
thing Gaza I disagree with your thing
these are not clashes at the border this
was a massacre of non-violent civilian
protesters by Israeli snipers there were
35 to 40 people killed murdered and over
2,000 people wounded with live
ammunition if this had been turned
around and Palestinians where the guns
had shot at Israeli demonstrators five
hundred yards across the fence this
would have been all over the press
non-stop day in and day out but the
Western
name any points may do development the
thing is like this first of all I must
say the achievements of the State of
Israel in all fields are not Jewish
achievements their achievements of the
State of Israel which means there are
also achievements of our Palestinians
brothers and sisters who are citizens of
the Satan of Israel and the Palestinian
leader living under occupation so of
course you have discrimination within
Israel but I would not I would not
ignore the the the tremendous the
important part of Palestinian they are
called Arab Israelis but Palestinian
with Israeli citizenship within Israel
in this in this miracle especially
economical miracle called Israel and the
thing is like this what happened in Gaza
shooting at a unarmed demonstrators most
of them are unarmed demonstrators I
agree with you and this is the thing I
agree with you and I think this is I
don't know if you know speaking about
one man one voice speaking about the end
of the Jewish state the end of the
Zionistic project basically the
Zionistic project it's you know what is
I anism is it creating a Jewish
sovereignity within the Middle East it
succeeded that's it so now we're in the
next phase but the again if we look at
the thing that that brings us together
the fact that that we here can sit and
speak and say okay we have common
grounds we disagree about certain things
the same thing we can do in Israel if we
say we find common grounds we find a
model of citizenship which takes the
Jewish part which we take the
Palestinian part I think this is
actually a chance I wouldn't say the end
of the Jewish state but I would say
rethinking sovereignty within Israel and
Palestine over there is the key point
which I completely disagree with you on
is because we can find its common ground
and sit here and talk because we're
living in Germany we were all the same
there's a long Israel if I was in Israel
you could come as a soldier and bar me
from coming to Tel Aviv by putting a
checkpoint outside of my house of
Ramallah but your house in Tel Aviv and
put a checkpoint in front of your house
and prevent you from coming to Jerusalem
that is the difference the difference is
that with when we are in Israel or in
Palestine we don't have the same rights
I cannot speak like
let's just let's just shift the focus
for a second and let's talk about ties
between Israel and Germany because we're
sitting here in Germany as we've just
noted talking about what's going on
between these Israelis and the
Palestinians very far away there have
been real tensions at times in the last
year or so between Israel and Germany
each side has snubbed the other but now
the relationship has it seems entered a
new phase on his first official visit to
Israel new German Foreign Minister Heiko
Maas wanted to strike a new tone in the
recently strained relations between the
two countries his efforts were well
received they reach our hearts they come
as I'm learning more and more from your
own history mass wants to build trust
and bring new impetus to solving old
problems I think that we are in
agreement on nearly all of our
objectives there are indeed differences
regarding the road to reaching them but
the place of Germany will always be
alongside Israel in all of these
questions still those differing views
are not on minor matters for instance
Germany continues to support a two-state
solution
despite Israel's controversial
settlement policy the positions of the
two countries here are poles apart so
how much friction can the German Israeli
friendship tolerate so much to talk
about so little time Shani is the German
government right to cling to the
two-state solution it's it's it's right
as much as any other government is right
to advocate for any other government to
do anything else in the sense that
Germany's is in the same line with many
most of other European nations and up
until recently the u.s. read regards to
what should be the solution to the to
the conflict will this make it closer to
end will this be eventually the solution
it's actually not up to Germany or
anyone else it's up to Palestinians and
Israelis and the two-state solution I
think is is an idea that on one hand
many can agree is is is the only way to
save Israel
but we have growing voices and growing
numbers of people supporting these
voices that maybe that sip has
ultra-trail sailed maybe it's too late
now and we need to find other solutions
like maybe a one state solution that is
a democratic state that gives we have
even we have within the sutlers and
within you know Palestinians that idea
if that is a route that the world could
go down is Germany an honest broker that
could facilitate their in that equation
I think Germany could facilitate could
be an honest broker just as the United
States could be an honest broker the
problem is that they when they say it
has to be the two sides who come up with
a solution
we are not neutral as Western countries
in this equation we the Western
countries the United States Germany have
given close to unconditional support
militarily economically and politically
to Israel while denying this to the
Palestinians so they're not honest
brokers they are not neutral in this
equation if they were then I think there
could be progress over it's interesting
when Heiko Maas the newer foreign
ministry of Germany entered office in
his first speech he said the reason I
went into politics is all fits
yeah and it was quarters all over and it
was it was given as an example that he's
going to have no a different Israel
politic than his predecessor a sigma
goblin but sigma goblin as well said i
am in politics because of my father who
was a national socialist all the way
until he died so Gabrielle grew in the
same in the same in the same context so
it just shows you that German in the
Israel perspective can go this way can
go that way so I don't think there is
one German voice regarding Israel I
think you know Israel calls itself a
liberal democracy and it is for its
citizen citizens and Israel ebrill
democracy not for all of inhabitants
excuse me mostly Jewish citizens
citizens but not all of the people
living under the Israeli rule for
instance the Palestinians leaver living
under occupation and this is the key
question what can Germany do because of
course as Jenny said to get involved in
the affairs of another of
another country is difficult but if
Israel calls itself a liberal democracy
and I think it should that should be the
goal of Israel then okay welcome to the
club in order to be a part of this club
you have to observe human rights you
have to observe equality for all
citizens I think it's it's it's it's
actually it's positive politics that the
German government are not only German
German government and can pursue and
excuse me if it's okay to send
submarines if it's okay to support
Israel in other manner in other matters
why is it not okay to take part and in
the in the regional politics where
Israel is a part of intermedius just say
though just quickly I don't think
Germany can ever be a neutral broker I
think as much as we we see a slight
change in German policy towards Israel a
bit more of a critical voices that are
there much more loud loud today than
they used to be in the past but I don't
see how is I mean Germans not necessary
because of Israel I don't see how
Germans let themselves be the ones
pressuring Israel because of the burden
of the past because of the fear because
of the discourse that we're so used to
that is dominated of that he's dominated
by that body left yeah very quickly is
that there was no Israel before 1948 the
Holocaust world war ii III don't like
world war ii being reduced to the
holocaust as horrible as it was the
entire war was terrible no Nazi Germany
of Sorrows or or it the fact is that
what happened happened to European Jews
and not the State of Israel the State of
Israel as far as I know does not speak
for every Jew in this world no matter
what it likes to proclaim it does not so
criticizing and putting pressure on the
State of Israel has nothing to do with
with being Jewish that's my point this
is highly important if I can add because
this touches a wound here in Germany
because very often we speak about Israel
and then we move to the discussion
regarding anti-semitism in Germany it is
not the same topic people who are pro
Israeli who goes to Israeli flags and
get into arguments on Berlin streets
because of that that's one thing people
are getting attacked because they have a
keeper on their head that's a different
thing
and I think it's the point that has to
be discussed it's not you know you can't
separate both that easily but it's it's
worth to bear it in mind when you speak
about anti-semitism in Europe in a
nutshell from each of you where do you
want the situation to go next
I want the situation I hope that there
is an end of this conflict and that can
only lead I can only be led through by
the end of the Israeli occupation of
Palestine and whether that is a one
state solution of democracy where
everyone one man one vote one woman one
vote in the Democratic state for a
two-state solution which in my opinion
no longer exists because the settlements
have eaten everything honey I think the
end goal is peace I think it's such a
big word what does it mean how do we get
there I don't know I think it's gonna be
a much longer process and we think and I
think we don't see any good development
any changes real changes in the next
decade partnership civil partnership
that's the that's the solution okay
thanks so much for your thoughts thanks
so much for being with us here today on
quadriga Israel at 70 a troubled
anniversary thank you see you next week
bye bye just
[Music]
you